[Music]
[Applause]
let's uh
bring in chris webber who is going into
the hall of fame do i have to
call you hall of famer now or do i can i
wait till next year chris
hey man i don't know man whatever
whatever you want to do is cool with me
okay but does your wife call you hall of
famer how's it work around the house
oh hell no she's happy but i know she'll
never call me that [ __ ]
you know she maybe she'll call me hall
of famer when i'm taking out the trash
or something
yeah but no my father he did it when i
called and told him
and uh it was it was a really it's a
really cool feeling having him be the
first to say it knowing that
you know my dad has never called me
anything but boy or son or
hey you know my whole life so it was
pretty cool how emotional was that for
you
when you called your dad you you know
tell the truth that i'm really like uh
still kind of
i want to call it state of shock but it
uh the weight of it hasn't hit me i know
what it means
or i'm continuing to learn what it means
uh but when i called my father that was
a special moment you know
you know parents they go through
everything and
just being a father young kids now i
can't imagine how my father and mother
did with five kids that would be married
50 years this summer in july
so it was a special you know special
moment from him as he got from sort of
mississippi he was just going through
his life saying you know
it's really cool i did it but as a
father he never thought as a child
when he was a child that you know he
would have kids uh
you know kind of do what his kids have
done so it's awesome you think robert
dory is a hall of famer
i think he's i think he's known for
winning
i think the teams that he's won
championships for all said they wouldn't
have won without him
um i know he took one for me so
i definitely have to uh i definitely
have to you know
put him in there just just because we
just you know
we talk about all these clutch players
and guys are clutching on the regular
season guys are clutched on that whole
career but
has there been anyone more clutch than
roberto
yeah i wondered about that though
because you know he didn't even score 10
000
points he wasn't a starter but when a
game was on the line he was the guy that
you
had to account for you can't write the
history of the nba without robert dorey
but i wonder what that cut off is i
mentioned that derek fisher has
five rings he's played in the i think
as many postseason games as anybody in
history
and i think he's tied with lebron so i
don't know you know we've been talking
about julian edelman with the patriots
is he a hall of famer even though he
wasn't a pro bowl player like it's kind
of weird that
you know you're trying to figure this
out uh it feels like a moving target
yeah and you know edelman was one of my
favorite players during the playoffs she
didn't care what he did during a regular
season you know he's going to be in that
little slot position
i'm gonna win this year uh but uh i'm
i'm a fan of different players
like for instance this year watch out
for the rams i have them early they're
going to the super bowl because they
have
my quarterback they got my quarterback
and so i'm following him but
um i was just you know yeah we're gonna
be good but
um you know it's really hard to tell the
last few years i've been thinking about
these conversations and
preparing players and stashing things
and it just kind of
it really gets messy when you know you
don't have any metrics to you know
compare
against and so it just starts to
the uh warriors with the lakers last
night what did you see that would be of
concern
if you're a laker fan
uh the slow start of the lakers uh the
fact that
uh they have to take drummond out uh you
know i thought that german was the prize
of the of the season because i thought
if he just came and did what he's
supposed to do and that's just
rebound just put back shots um
just played defense i thought they were
going to be really intense and really
tough
i still think the the lakers are my
favorite with those three
but um it would concern me the slow
start that they got off to because you
can't really do that in the playoffs
especially not against uh
great coach teams like phoenix and
others but you got phoenix now coming up
with the lakers fare better against
phoenix than they would utah
that's a good question i i think the
lakers are just when they're playing
damn defense i mean defensively when
vogel is done with them
i just love it and so defensively
they're so long and switch they
communicate
um whether it's caruso or whether it's
a.d and so
i like them defensively i don't know who
would be the tougher i think
utah is probably happy that they get to
wait and hopefully get that point guard
back
but right now i just think that no
matter who la's
no matter who the lakers play they're
gonna have to play with the same sense
of urgency because
they don't have uh they don't have that
room to just play around
when you get switched on lebron what's
that feeling like
whoa uh the first thing you do is look
at what
ball he has hand here what hand he has
the ball in
then you tried to shade him to that side
and then you're going like this
which means y'all better be in the back
and help you know i was there
i was there in detroit man and uh i
really honestly thought
that the pistons you know was gonna be
my first chance to win the championship
because that was one of the best locker
rooms i was in
and he had 25 i think on this in the
fourth quarter and i've never seen
anything like that with some of the best
defenders on the pistons that i've ever
played with
so he's so strong first his iq is
incredible he's so strong
he takes the shots that he wants and
then right when
you think that you're doing your best
job and help comes
he finds somebody else in the corner and
you know i mean bowie gibson or whoever
hit
six threes on this because we were going
after lebron so he's
he's one of the greatest just because um
he understands how great he is
and he's unselfish so he's tough does he
talk trash
no he wasn't talking trash to me no but
i mean i think he did maybe the rip and
guys he knew a little bit but now
you know he's gonna i think he studied
jordan and those guys so
he waits for the big shot at a big
moment and you know kind of talks
junk with his gestures or his eyes you
see him hit the three last time stay
calm that was kind of a gesture
right there you know in itself but
you're like i don't have to talk joke
because
but jordan didn't talk until it was a
big moment
so during the early part of a game he
wouldn't say anything oh no jordan to
talk all
no yeah juwan and i joanne uh thanks for
the shirt by the way
juwan and i um jerome's from chicago we
play against uh
jordan in the summer those type of
things and so we would talk to jordan
because
and i felt like we had nothing to lose
and
let's just give it our all and have some
great stories to tell our kids about so
yeah jordan
oh he would talk from if he wanted to
talk he would talk and again i think i
told you the story about the playoffs
when we got off the bus
and inside of a non-smoking building
jordan's smoking a cigar
before the game standing and leaning on
his ferrari
as we're getting off the bus and he goes
hey chris juwan who's gonna check me
tonight and we were i've always prided
myself on being like the best teammate
but this night i let my man down because
we both looked back and said calvert got
[ __ ]
he gave us 55. in the playoff game
uh he gave calvert 55. he didn't give
you
55. he probably gave me about 17 of them
but we just i mean
calvert looked at this too it was it was
uh hall of famer chris webber joining us
on the program that was a nice moment
with you and jalen rose
on espn uh don't know it's a long time
coming but is it more than that or was
it just
that that moment that you guys got to
share
it was just that moment um i didn't know
he was going to interview me
i thought maria was and you know right
before the interview
uh he interviewed me and so um
everything i said when i met and i said
it you know before in other interviews
but he knows i mean
i mean you got to go into a room and
talk fight wrestle something
you know so that was a great moment but
from all the papers but from what i
heard
you know we made up and things like that
we still haven't talked with roman so
that was the first time we talked um it
was uh
awesome moments especially for our
parents our family i love your sister
you know our families are
close um but yeah no we still have to
talk
yeah because a lot of times you'll have
family members who don't talk to family
members
but everybody else in the family goes
why don't you two just get in a room and
talk
yeah that's that's that's you know uh
what happened
up until the day his beautiful mother
um um had her home going you know
our parents were close you know every
everybody's closed that's that's what it
is it's just an issue of
he knows what it is we just have to go
into a room and talk that's just that's
just
that's just the way that i am i've
always been like okay i get the world
i get you know the games and everything
but true friends
should be able to you know talk and have
fun
who knows maybe you know we'll be you
know sitting up there arguing on tv one
day and you never know so
you know i think that's coming uh
relationship you know
talking all that but no that was our
first conversation and you know
it was it was a really uh it was at a it
was at a really cool time
and uh you know it's something that
somebody played with at the age of 13 is
actually on
one of the best networks ever in sports
and they get to
introduce you so it was uh it was a
moment of you know whoa i haven't talked
to them
wow this is pretty cool remember the
stuff we used to do and then it was just
more so of
you know just being in the moment so i
no matter how it happened i appreciate
it the moment i appreciate it
being able to share that uh with all of
detroit you know having to
do the interview but yeah we didn't talk
but it wasn't
hopefully it's a start yeah hopefully
it's a start
um congrats on the uh the hall of fame
chris
and uh we appreciate your time as always
love the stories and uh
hope to uh talk to you again soon hope
to talk to you soon soon
thanks that's uh chris webber member of
the 2021 basketball hall of fame
class we'll take a break we got our play
of the day coming up next dan patrick
show